every Tuesday it's time for a high on
money series taking a look at financial
issues affecting Americans so this
morning how overspending on credit cards
can affect your finances for years it's
happened to a lot of us a very big club
out there the average u.s. household is
a credit card debt of about fifty seven
hundred dollars that's according to an
analysis of census and Federal Reserve
data overall consuming debt consumer
debt rather has been rising
significantly since the recession more
than ten years ago it exceeded four
trillion dollars in June joining us to
help sort it all out as Ted Rothman he's
an industry in analyst at banc rate.com
and joins us at the table hey Ted good
morning I got in trouble in college I
had a credit card bills of $1,500
because they just pass them out to you
in college yeah you think well I need to
get two or three of those before that
you're overwhelmed with fifteen hundred
dollars in debt I thought I'll never get
out of this so I took a consolidation
loan have you heard of those
consolidation loans are great you want
to make sure they'll recommend I do look
for nonprofits though look for somebody
accredited by the NFC see the National
Foundation for credit counseling and FCC
org is a great resource if it's a
nonprofit like money management
international there's low fees there's a
lot of benefits the for-profit ones
though the debt settlement companies
that can destroy your credit but this is
the thing we keep hearing the economy's
doing so well so why is your credit card
debt so high credit card debt is easy to
get into and hard to get out of so
what's happening for a lot of people is
in emergency strikes something with
their health their car their home 30
million Americans don't have health
insurance 40% don't even have $400 saved
up so when something hits like the
transmission breaks you got to get to
work it goes on a credit card yeah and
the double whammy is that the average
interest rate is 18% so it's easy to get
in and hard to get it so what is the
what is the best way to approach paying
off a significant credit card debt I
love balance transfer cards you can get
these for as long as 21 months with no
interest now be careful of transfer fees
most of these will charge you three to
five percent upfront right you're
basically by the way you're basically
transferring your debt from one car
to another with a lower interest rate
exactly zero percent the ones I like are
15 months and they don't charge the
transfer fee that's why I like those is
that gaming the system you have any time
yeah well you don't want to make a habit
out of it you don't want to keep kicking
the can down the road but I recommend
the chase slate the AMEX every day and
the BankAmericard do this be disciplined
about it don't put new money on the card
try to figure out exactly how much do
you need to pay and knock it out in
those 15 months if you've made good
headway and you need to do one more of
these I think that would be okay don't
make it a habit though there's a
lifestyle component to this - yeah it's
behavioral quickly Ted these these debt
free commercials these these companies
that promise to get you debt free in 12
or 24 months do you trust them I don't
like the debt settlement companies
because that destroys your credit
basically what they're gonna do is
they're gonna tell you to stop paying
for about six months and they're gonna
use that as leverage to try to negotiate
a lower bill it destroys your credit
don't do debt settlement debt
consolidation nonprofit credit
counseling personal loans balance
transfers those are good don't do the
debt settlement if you do the debt
settlement the credit card company's not
getting as much money money either I can
imagine if you got into credit card
trouble because of an emergency and then
you're getting hit with fees and then
you're getting it with more interest up
and up and up it would feel pretty good
does it screw you to the companies I'm
gonna say second to last resort though
bankruptcy is the last resort debt
settlements the second to last it's
gonna hurt your credit for seven to ten
years well that's a long time it's a
long time but you could savor it Ted
thank you very much I appreciate it Tony
you've got credit card debt you've been
in credit card debt
people know what I'm talking about